الذئب الذي كان في فوضى
عارمة داخل حريق القمامة داخل
حطام قطار كان أسوأ نقاش
رأيته على الإطلاق في الواقع
لم يكن حتى نقاشًا ، لقد كان
وصمة عارًا
، ويرجع ذلك أساسًا إلى الرئيس
ترامب
أه الذي قضى كل الوقت في
مقاطعة
عدم الالتزام بالقواعد التي وافق
على الكذب
بمهاجمة نجل
نائب الرئيس
عندما طُلب منه أه يدين المتعصبين للبيض ،
فقد طرح اسم مجموعة من الفاشية الجديدة اليمينية
المتطرفة وقال: توقفوا ووقفوا
سأتحدث عنها.  من ربح المناظرة
وخسر المناظرة ولكن يمكنني أن أقول لك
شيئًا واحدًا مؤكدًا أن الشعب الأمريكي
فقد
الليلة لأن ذلك كان مروعًا ،
لقد أخرجت الكلمات من فمي
أم أنك استخدمت بعض اللغة السامية
سأقولها فقط
كما لو كان هذا عرضًا هراءًا
وأنت تعلم أننا على الكابل يمكننا أن نقول إن
الاعتذار لكونك
فظًا بعض الشيء ، لكن هذه في
الحقيقة هي العبارة التي أتلقى المزيد مما
تعرفه من الأشخاص على كلا الجانبين
أيسل  e على
النص وهي العبارة الوحيدة التي يمكنني
التفكير فيها لوصفها حقًا
ولا يمكنني أن أتفق معك أكثر من
ذلك ، لكن الأشخاص
الذين تأذوا أكثر من هؤلاء هم
الأشخاص الذين
يتطلعون بصدق لمعرفة موقف كل
مرشح
من أجل ومن يجب أن يصوتوا له ،
لا يزال
هناك أشخاص لم
يتخذوا قرارًا بشأن أي مرشح
يصوتون له
أو ما إذا كانوا سيصوتون ولست متأكدًا من
ذلك بشكل خاص فيما يتعلق بالنقطة الأخيرة
أن هذا الأداء
وأن  المسرح هناك ، برنامج تلفزيون
الواقع ، سيساعدهم برنامج تلفزيون الواقع السيئ
في أقل تقدير ، نعم ، أعني أنها كانت
كارثة كاملة على
جميع الجبهات وأعتقد أنه إذا
كنت تعتقد
أنك تعرف رجلين في السبعينيات من العمر
يريدان ذلك  كن زعيمًا للعالم الحر
خلال السنوات الأربع المقبلة ، فقد
يكون لديك تبادل معقول للأفكار
التي خرجت من هذا النقاش معتقدًا
أن هذا غير ممكن
لأنك بالكاد تستطيع سماعها
في نقاط معينة كان هناك الكثير من
التقارب  كل
واحد على الآخر ولكن جيك كما
أشرت يجب أن نكون واضحين حقًا
هنا هذا
ليس أه كلا الجانبين نوع الموقف
كان هناك طرف واحد في تلك المرحلة
يقاطع
الصراخ على الوسيط
ومنذ البداية أعتقد أن ما كان مذهلاً للغاية
لمشاهدة أن هذه النقاشات عادة
ما تبنى وتبني حتى النهاية ،
بدأنا في 12 على مقياس من 1 إلى
10. الرئيس كان حقًا كما تعلم ،
أعتقد أنه كان في حالة هياج للغاية في
وقت مبكر جدًا من النقاش و  تم ضبط النغمة
من ذلك
2 لقد سمعت بالفعل من أشخاص
يؤيدون كثيرًا الرئيس يريدون منه
أن يقوم بعمل جيد ،
آه لأن هذا كان يحدث لكنه كان
حارًا جدًا لدرجة أنهم كانوا يعلمون أنه
سيكون عدوانيًا كما عرفوا نحن  تحدثت
عنه مسبقًا
أنه سيحاول أن يكون في حالة
إهانة قدر الإمكان ،
لكن هذا استغرق الأمر بعيدًا جدًا حتى بالنسبة إلى دونالد
ترامب